uh we have to put it where
what is the logic of mediapart
must learn it
that's what it is when you tell me
that's what it is
that's what you tell me
that she should not be treated because she is my mother
uh erikciotti
the media-parte newspaper accuses you
in a thorough investigation
to take advantage of public money to hospitalize
your mother your mother who has had a stroke
and who has been hospitalized for years
in a care structure that
usually only welcomes patients of
short-term care,
which allows it to be
one hundred percent reimbursed by social security
which would not be the case
if it was uh in a structure adapted to uh
this long-term pathology
what do you say to this
I think that now we reach the top of the ignoble
uh we went
uh go through my mother's medical records
who is fifty-eight years old
suffered a stroke
who is quadriplegic
who lives on a bed of suffering
uh who uh needs precise care
I'm not the one managing his hospitalization
they are doctors
who decided uh his situation
to do I never intervened
with anyone
and in any way
say that my mother can't
have the right to certain care
uh in the state where it is
uh it's disgusting it's ignoble